hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome and really complicated game from
the final round of the women's chess
olympiad 2022. uh it is a game between
uh first board for ukraine maria music
and first board for paul and alina
kaslinskaya uh and like i said it's it's
a really complicated game it will make
your head spin and uh well uh of course
there is quite a lot to enjoy about it
uh due to that now maria music needs no
re real introduction she is uh
she was a world champion from 2015 from
2016 and she won a goal uh not gold but
she won medals for uh ukraine in in five
olympiads in 2022 also you guys know
that ukraine won uh gold so that's uh
you know an incredible resume and alina
carson uh she is the
2019 uh european chess champion uh
european women's chess champion and also
a very very uh
strong chess player she has there's the
title of international master and
women's grand master uh so uh that's a
little bit of an intro but the game is
what we are uh really uh here to see so
let's dive into it as there is a lot
there is so much to enjoy in this game
so i apologize for uh showing uh a few
variations uh too many uh so uh maria
muzichuk has the white pieces and she
opens with e4 and i forgot to mention
both of them have had an incredible
tournament only losing one game each uh
winning most of their games and and
drawing some uh so here pawn to e6 we
have d for d5 knights the c3 and the
bishop to b4 of another variation of the
french so nothing out of the ordinary
here we have e5 and now usually uh we
all only see pawn to c5 here this is
pretty much an automatic but here alina
goes knight to e7 it's the second most
popular option and it allows uh white
uh well to to maybe rush things maybe go
uh or over uh you know uh too quickly uh
point is if you go for the standard
queen to g4 which is a move that you
usually play in uh in such lines uh
black can now reply with c5 and now the
standard queen captures on g7 is no
longer an option because rook g8 and now
after you capture an h7 there's pawn
captures on d4 and now what do you do
about the knight you can play a3 of
course saying okay you capture my knight
i'm going to capture a bishop but then
queen a5 let's say and now you have to
give up your rook you can only play
capture some b4 rook a queen captures on
a1
and already black is much much better
here so yeah it's a little bit different
than going c5 right away and many things
are possible here so here uh we have a3
uh by uh music this is uh the the best
way to play this and the most common one
bishop character spawn captures and now
pawn to c5 and only now queen the g4
in instead of going to g4 which is by
far the the most played here you could
also go h4a4 is possible knight to f3 is
possible but she continues in the
absolute main line queen g4 and now
queen to c7 preparing c captures on d4
putting pressure on the center here now
queen captures on g7 attacking the rook
rook to g8 and queen captures on h7 so
this is all very very standard theory of
this poison pawn variation of the winner
and if you don't know exactly how to
play it you will get crushed with white
and with black so be very careful if you
decide to ever play this c captures on
d4 and now knight to e2 of course here
if you play if you recapture queen the
c3 check just picks up the rook so i
know you guys weren't considering that
knight to e2 now defending the c3 pawn
and here we have knight beat the c6 just
continuing development you might think
but why not capture this e5 pawn it's so
yeah i mean it's it's literally uh you
know inviting us to capture it the
problem is if queen captures here now uh
uh c captures on d4 is incredibly strong
as uh by playing knight d2 you also
control the f4 square and now bishop to
f4 is coming so this is very very
unpleasant for the black queen if queen
goes back queen d6 queen c7 uh we can
just attack it bishop to f4 now if you
capture on c2 of course we have rook to
c1
then black has all sorts of problems so
best for black is to play some like
queen a5 check we're going to block with
the bishop once the queen moves now we
play c3 and it seems like black achieved
something
but not really for example knight beat
the c6 we're going to play knight to g3
to cover the g2 pawn and after bishop d7
we're going to play rook to b1 as the
queen guards the b1 square and it is all
white in this game queen c7 bishop to b5
we nicely develop after black castles
now we can play queen captures on f7
uh let's say rook d to f8 goes after the
queen queen h5 now let's say knight to
f5 and we're just gonna castle knight to
d6 uh it's uh you know both players both
of them are playing but white is up two
pawns so uh unless uh you you really
mess up something you are gonna win this
no no questions asked so that's the
problem of capturing the e5 pawn i'm
sure you had this position many times
and you were like uh you know what to
play here
that's
something you don't play so knight b to
c6 this is the absolute strongest and
now f4 and here we have d captures on c3
showing that she is not afraid uh bishop
to d7 is just the the safer option you
know just really preparing to castle
quickly but the captures on c3 she says
i'm here to fight uh and okay queen back
to d3 now preparing to pick up the d3
pawn and here again bishop to d7 most
common uh she goes for d4 uh really
challenging mariam muzichuk to see if if
she knows her lines uh and okay knight
captures on d4 now you have to trade if
you don't trade knight b5 knight to d6
black just gets destroyed tonight
captures on d4 queen captures and only
now bishop the d7 preparing to put the
bishop on c6 and then you have a whole
lot of pressure on the white white's
king side so rook g1 and now knight to
f5 attacking the queen here queen to f2
adding a defender to the g2 pawn and now
queen the c6 first
uh preparing queen to d5 a very nice
centralizing move and only then the
bishop will go to c6 and bear in mind we
are already at move 16 and this is all
standard theory of this poison point
variation of the winner uh bishop to d3
and now queen to d5 uh preparing bishop
to c6 and now
this position has been reached many many
times uh the the most played move here
is rook to b1 it's been played in a game
between uh lake o peter and fabiano
korwan has been played in a game between
duda and bartel has been played in a
game between ganguly and shulman
all of these games have ended in a draw
but instead of rook to b1 we have bishop
to e3 now
when you talk about preparation rook to
b1 and bishop to e3 are both kind of
equally valued by the engine so it's i
guess it's a matter of taste
but bishop to e3 is what music decided
to play here so let's see how the game
continues knight captures on e3 uh we
have queen captures on a3 and now rook
captures on g2 grabbing that g2 pawn
winning the pawn back now the material
is equal rook captures queen captures
and now the very important bishop to e4
now you can see that the king covers f1
queen covers g1 bishop covers h1 so you
don't have any checks you don't have a
way of maybe picking up the rook on a1
so queen captures an h2 and now we have
queen side castles you could also go for
bishop captures on b7 but then you give
black counter play and that's no way to
push for any advantage queen side
castles is the way to go
but this makes the game incredibly
incredibly complicated uh bishop the c6
of course not allowing bishop capture
sun b7 now bishop characters and c6b
captures in c6 and now the beautiful
centralizing queen to d4 uh putting
pressure on the black king preventing
rook to d8 now we have pawn to a5 not
allowing this to remain a target here
and there is a game where rook to g1 was
played hoping to get that rook to g18
but here we have pawn to f5
and it is only now as of move 25 that we
have a completely new game
and this is basically where our game
begins uh so that's how much theory
there is on the poison variation of the
of the uh french winner uh so what do
you play here e captures on f5 you have
to play this and now king to b1 king to
b1 is an incredibly important move uh
because it uh
it prepares king to a1 once the king
reaches the a1 square it's it is
incredible how safe the white king here
is uh the problem is if black plays
something like rook to b8 to check and i
mean who amongst us would not play rook
to b8 to check here you would play this
in bullet blitz i mean you you play this
whatever you play the problem is after
the king moves king to a1 black is just
lost now the rook is incredibly
vulnerable here uh let's say you play
queen captures on c2 you want to
checkmate the white king we just play
queen to d7 checking f8 and now of
course queen to d6 with check
and that's it the rook is either falling
with check or if you go to g7 then you
are getting checkmate rook to g1 check
king here and now of course we play
really whatever we can even capture the
rook as we cover checkmate here so
regardless of what you play you are
winning here and another thing after
king to a1 uh okay black doesn't have to
capture on c2 you could also play
something like rook back to a8 again
it's insufficient just queen d6 now
threatening queen captures and c6 and
there is uh
not nothing you can do so king the king
the b1 uh was an incredible move also
just baiting that rook to b8 which is uh
completely unplayable so here we have
king to f8 this is the absolute best way
to defend and now queen to d6 with check
and this is how complicated this entire
variation is uh imagine this king the g8
uh is losing for black and king the g7
uh is just a very very pleasant position
to play for black i mean which is
incredible if you if you just look at
this position and i will show you why uh
because uh after king to g7 which was
not played in the game uh
or rather i'm not gonna show it to you
i'm just gonna tell you that king to g8
was played and now you should pause the
video and to win the game for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
brilliant brilliant maneuver and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course queen to e7 uh so
whoever found this or truly
congratulations you are an amazing
player uh and i will now show you why
this is so uh this would not work if the
king was on g7 and the whole point is
that uh now for example queen to e7 is
met with c5 this is a beautiful
defensive resource that clears the
entire sixth rank for the black rook we
want to play rook to a6 and put the rook
on g6 to prevent any future rook to g1
ideas also queen to g5 can be annoying
so point is now after king the a1 which
is a move that white has to play if
white is to start attacking rook to a6
now we're going to play queen to g5
check rook to g6 and now let's say queen
captures an f5 rook to g1 and okay it's
it's it's a draw queen to f6 check
there's really nothing better for white
to try here we're just gonna have a nice
repetition here however after this um uh
queen to d6 check move king to g uh
eight was played and now uh you guys
found the incredible queen to e7 and now
the same thing no longer applies because
as the king is here uh the problem is
after c5 and now look at this king the
a1 rook to a6 you cannot play this
because now the king is on the back rank
not on g7 and there is this incredible
rook to d8 check and now the whole line
doesn't work because after king to g7
you just start a king hunt and there is
no way for black to survive this queen
to g8 checking the h5 now queen captures
on f7 checking the g4 or you could just
uh well pretty much anything is winning
here rook the g8 checking f4 queen to c4
with check king the e3 queen captures
with czech king to e2 and now you just
finish the attack queen d3 check
king t1 queen to e3 check king to f1 and
now rook d8 going for rook to d1 uh and
of course if you block this queen to e2
we can play queen for checking t1 and
queen to c1 check and now after king f2
we just play rook to d2 so uh we win the
queen and of course the game so you
can't go for this uh defensive resource
that was possible if the king was on on
g7 so here instead we have queen to f2
uh a beautiful beautiful defensive idea
but only if you make a mistake here so
here uh feel free to pause the video
once again and try to find the only
winning move for uh maria music while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on always thinking
about that prophylactic idea and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is king to a1 that's the way to
play it and this is what uh music played
and now there is really nothing for
uh for alina to try point is if you if
you don't play this if you try anything
else let's say you try e6 which is kind
of the whole point uh then just queen b6
check and what do you play if king here
or king here or king here doesn't really
matter you just get to check mated so
that's the problem so king they won
incredibly strong in that position
which was played in the game now comes
queen to g2 but it doesn't help now e6
just blasts blasts through and that's it
f captures an e6 queen captures an e6
king the h8 and now queen captures an f5
with check
and the black king is now completely
vulnerable there's no way to go uh after
the white king rook the a7 was played
trying to add another defender to the to
the seventh rank but now rook to d8
would check whatever you play you get
checkmated somewhere else king to g7
queen to f8 to check king to g6 now
comes rook to d6 with check and he was
in this position on move 35 that alina
karstenskaya resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here once you
play a few more moves king g5 just queen
g8 to check you can pick up the black
queen and of course black will resign
here
so incredible incredible game you can
see i had 25 moves of known theory and
then uh you know such such incredible
decisions uh had to be made here uh
basically uh
uh what's incredible about this is that
after uh we had the the completely new
new move with f5 uh basically only uh uh
this one move this is two moves and this
is three moves so after known theory it
only took three moves to get a
completely winning position for mariamo
which is uh uh often the case when you
play these exhausting engine lines i
don't know if you guys remember that
game between the shakhtar mom and the
arrow and danish geary where they played
like 23 moves of known theory then
mamidarov like made the first move out
of his head and then you know he was
just minus 50 and uh you know anish won
the game or maybe it wasn't unique i'm
pretty sure it was mamadara in someone
else uh but yeah that's what happens
when you play these really really long
exhausting engine lines it's very very
easy to go wrong and i mean uh who who
who who would think that king to g7 is
the way to go and king the g8 just loses
the game but when you are the one
defending i've learned that often going
forward is is the uh you know correct
way to defend and you know sometimes
when you're defending when someone is
coming at you maybe keep this in mind
maybe instead of you know just you know
sticking to that back rank maybe just go
forward and the
good things might happen you you could
also maybe uh in you know get the rook
into the game this way so anything is
possible
uh but yeah really really awesome game
by by mariam chuk uh uh taking down
alina karsanskaya and also uh
this means that ukraine won this match
and also they won the entire thing so
ukraine are the winners of the uh
women's chess olympiad defeating poland
three to one uh mariam muzuchi defeated
alina kashmitskaya uh ana music
defeated monica
yeah
defeated kilwa who had an incredible
tournament uh kyobasa olivia kobasa had
like 10 out of 10 i mean it was an
incredible run she she completely out of
the goo kished the gookash
and uh then in the final round he she
lost to
ushanina and also uh malice kalos uh or
alex has drew her game against buksa in
the uh uh on board four so it was uh
really really uh
an incredible final round and these are
the standings of the women's chess
olympiad so you guys can
see what's what ukraine tied with
georgia with match points you can see
both of them 18 points but ukraine
better additional criteria 30 and a half
to 29 then with 17 points we have uh
united states of america india and
kazakhstan it's it was a very
heartbreaking for india not to
win one of the three places as they uh
uh well they were sort of the clear
winners for for the entire uh entirety
of the olympiad and then in the final
round thing just didn't go their way and
they they missed out on uh you know on
the on the podium uh then with 16 points
we have poland india two azerbaijan
bulgaria germany uh armenia hungary
serbia and slovakia with 15 points we
have mongolia india three lithuania
czech republic netherlands uh and so on
uh so those are the final uh standings
of the women's chess olympiad uh so yeah
really really a tough pie a fight really
an incredible game you can see that if
you if you really don't know your stuff
when you play this uh whatever variation
i mean i've played it uh with white i've
never played it with black i mean i mean
i'm not you know i've never tried
learning it with black uh but you know
when you play it it really you know can
go can go either way because it's so so
so sharp so aggressive so i mean it's an
incredible
uh incredible opening
uh but yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it really really wild stuff
i mean 25 moves of known theory i i
can't really remember when was the last
time we had that uh but yeah
congratulations to the team ukraine on
winning the women's um uh chess olympiad
and uh well we will we'll see uh what
will happen as the next olympiad will be
in
uzbekistan as fida already announced it
uh in in 2026. uh so yeah once again
really hope you enjoyed this i would
like to thank michael colbert just
connects us kissing kathleen althea
cashman and robert aratum for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions until the start of the big
miami tournament uh so thank you all uh
i'll see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day